hey everyone and welcome back to the
beginner to Master februn episode number
16 if you caught the last one I did
break 1000 ELO now there's been a lot of
comments asking for longer episodes so
I'll try and deliver today with a long
one but before we get to the chess I do
want to give a big thank you to the
sponsor of today's video which is better
help chess can be an emotional roller
coaster one moment you're a tactical
genius the next you're blendering your
queen and questioning all all your
decisions it's actually a fitting
metaphor for life and if you're ever
feeling pinned down in life and you need
someone to talk to then therapy can
really help and this is where better
help comes in their mission is to make
therapy accessible and affordable
regardless of where you live or what
issues you may be facing better help is
an online platform that makes finding a
therapist as easy as solving this
Checkmate in one puzzle just be careful
not to stalemate by filling out a few
questions better help will match you
with a professional licensed therapist
and as little as 40 hours if you want to
give it a try click the link in the
video description betterhelp.com
erren to get 10% off your first month of
betterhelp and join the over 4 million
people who have used betterhelp to live
a happier and healthier life now thanks
again to betterhelp for sponsoring this
video and now let's get back to the
chess okay let's hop into it joining the
10-minute pool playing burum B
and we have a what do we call a center
game this could be the beginning of a
Danish if we see C3 but Queen takes D4
is a center game
opening uh and generally against this it
makes sense just to develop and attack
the queen and the downside for this for
white is a queen is spending few moves
uh in the opening rather than white
developing the minor pieces Queen E3 is
I think the best move and here I can
continue
developing there is a line where white
can play E5 and then Knight
G4
which okay which we're entering um I
have studied this before but from an
understanding point of view uh I do have
to move the Knight I can't play Queen E7
cuz it would not actually be a pin and
when I move the Knight I hit the que and
I hit the pawn on E5 and I I'll start
with uh with this move but there is a
tricky line that if white plays Queen
E2 and I take the pawn then white could
play F4 so in the event of Queen E2 or
queen
E4 pretty sure there is something kind
of important that black has to
do but I'll wait for my opponent to
move before I go further in explanation
opponent disconnected maybe having some
uh some Wi-Fi
issues uh there's other options for the
queen too but I think these are the two
of the trickier moves with Queen
F4 now I don't mind taking the pawn um I
was going to say and I can show it after
the game that if the queen stayed on on
the E file I would have probably played
D6 but uh for now yeah let's just in the
pawn and okay White's moving the queen
for what this is the fourth time in the
first seven moves white is pinning the
Knight so the threat is to play F4 to
win the knight uh but generally when the
queen is so exposed in the center you
just want to look for ways to attack it
and D5 is a very simple
move going to force the queen to move
again not on E5 is defended
we see Queen E2 so white is still
threatening to play
F4 despite White's breaking some opening
principles I still have to be careful
here and I mean the I think the simplest
choices are Bishop E7 or Bishop
E6 but anything else to
consider I'd like to be like if bit more
active like I'm looking for ways to make
it so if white plays F4 then I can
somehow punish white
but not seeing
anything super obvious I probably don't
want to overthink things like Bishop
E7 very stable move preparing to Castle
the goal in this position is to get Rook
to E8 as quickly as possible E5 f is the
only open file white has a queen and
king onlined on that
file so white finally developed
something that's not the
queen uh Knight C3 logical
move I could consider playing
D4 I think in this case why not like
attack the Knight grab some
space if Knight E4 then I can decide
probably between
in um there's definitely a lot of
attacking type
moves okay even here with Knight B5 I
could play A6 if I want Knight is then
probably going to be forced to
A3 yeah let's do it
A6 so far this game has been a matter
of like basically attacking my
opponent's pieces gaining a lot of
time and uh yeah now I can probably just
Castle I mean pretty soon I want to look
for opportunities to be forcing like
Bishop B4 or Bishop takes
A3 um with then the idea of playing Rook
E8 and exploiting E file so white moves
a knight another time I mean I could
trade if I want make the queen move
again and then develop with tempo
to attack the queen again so Knight
takes C4 is an
option another option is to start with
Bishop B4
check cuz C3 I'm happy to take it and if
Bishop D2 then maybe uh just make this a
bit cleaner Bishop B4 Bishop D2 and then
Rook
E8 and then I'm setting up a bunch
of nasty threats with eile
let's go for that Bishop
B4 yeah sometimes in chess it's
uh it can be hard to punish the opponent
immediately for breaking principles like
still requires
patience still have to follow principles
yourself but here I'm just trying to
optimize my
pieces I'm realizing that like Bishop D2
Rook E8 why could queenside Castle
maybe I'm not getting anything
there all right I do have Knight takes
C4 as
well I kind of have to
choose which path I want to
follow like there's a lot of goodlooking
options
here yeah Rook E8 queenside Castle I
don't see anything immediate like I have
Discovery potential
[Music]
potential I do have Bishop G4 there
actually Bishop
G4 okay I'm going to play Rook
E8 think in in this time control it's
important to not overthink things too
much like have to save my
time to hopefully convert my advantage
too so white does Castle now I'm going
to play Bishop G4 so I mean basically
the principle has been just accelerate
development I have all my minor pieces
developed the Rook align with a
queen and in these cases usually there's
bound to be
tactics the tactic I'm looking at is if
F3 then I could take on
F3 we see Queen E4 but so I I still have
the discovery against the queen and if I
move the Knight I leave my my Bishop
undefended also The Rook is
hanging it's getting a little bit weird
here debating between taking the Rook
first or taking the Knight first both
options look pretty
good I'm going to take the Knight
first cuz I'm hitting the queen and
hitting the
bishop white could take on G4 I'll take
on
D2 and life will be very
good take on D2
with the Knight or Bishop maybe the
Knight I'll take with the Knight so the
knight's not a Target on
C4 kind of a weird game thus
far but I've managed to win a
piece and if takes takes
then I guess black will be up up a rook
and pawn for
Bishop we see Knight
F3 so I'm debating whether to take the
bishop or the
Knight I think I'll take the Knight
Bishop still
undeveloped it's possible white okay I
was going to say white could take back
with the G pawn and use the G file maybe
but
um yeah we C takes with Queen so I think
I'll play Queen
G5 forcing the king to
B1 it's very tempting to like look for
back rank mates the queen D2 then takes
and I'm not mating cuz the Rook can move
back so I don't want to be overly fancy
I think I'll just get my final piece
into
play if white develops and I can
potentially play Knight
E5 and then Force some
exchanges
yeah let's play ight E5 we'll up the
tempo a little
bit with this move I do leave B7
undefended but I actually don't mind was
that a mouse
slip maybe white intended this move
but maybe white also missed the fact the
pawn could take um I'm not sure there
there's no option to give a take back so
opponent resigns okay a slightly abrupt
finish I was going to say that if Queen
takes B7 I would have been happy to have
the B file open and then the plan would
have been to probably first take the
bishop let's say Rook
takes and even a move like Rook B8 like
give away one of these
pawns and uh and go for the the B file
pressure if we got to this position
white would maybe have to play this and
then the bishop and pawn have a very
nice combo um maybe I could snag on G2
or find a way to get my queen to A3 and
B2 but anyway I think that was a nice
example of how
to punish the opponent for just moving
the queen too many times and then moving
the Knight of few too many times in the
opening uh before we move on to the next
game I do want to
show what I think is a an important
opening idea for anyone that might play
this as black and if white plays Queen
E2
then it would be a blunder here to take
on E5 because of f4 and then black is
losing the Knight it's just a simple
simple pin along the E file so rather
than taking the pawn uh it's best for
black to actually Gambit and play the
move D6 which defends a knight and if
white takes yeah it looks scary because
White just W another pawn and is
checking the king and uh yeah black can
block and let's say takes then black can
take back and if we count material
Black's down a pawn but there's just
huge development huge leaning
development for black ideas of Knight D4
and queen side castling and just getting
all the pieces into play and this is
already completely winning according to
stockfish so it's useful thing to know
that and sometimes in opening you you
want to focus more on peace activity
over
material um and this is a nice example
of that so hopefully some lessons to
take away let's move on to the next game
playing Abu
diabi and I'll play
E4 so rating has gone up to
1,025 I'll play the Italian
at some point in this series I'll
probably mix up the
openings uh usually I play D3 I think in
this game I I'll play
C3 this is an opening I learned around
the 1,000
ELO and the idea is to very simply
expand with Pawn D4 get Tempo on the
bishop and pawn D4 is supported by the
pawn the Knight and the queen so a move
like Knight F6 or D6 white can still
play D4 and the pawn is supported enough
times now this opening I believe is
called the um actually chess.com says
it's called the Joko piano Center attack
I think there's a variation called the
Moler attack which maybe we'll go
into black is so far playing all the
most natural moves Bishop B4 check and
in this position there's two moves
there's Bishop D2 and Knight C3 I think
Knight D2 is also move although it's
pretty rare uh the move I liked to play
when I was younger was Knight
C3 this is one of the first openings my
very first chess coach taught to me uh
shout out to Tamara
goov uh she was one of my first coaches
and also the the coach of Boris gond and
Yuri Schulman and she taught me an
opening growing up that if black takes
the pawn then I can Castle King side
essentially sacrificing another
pawn and there's cases where white
will sacrifice a bit of material to get
a lot of opening
initiative so we'll see if black wants
to uh snag the pawn
here and we do see Bishop takes C3 so uh
we're actually going down a line that I
learned when I was probably like eight
or 9 years old uh so this is bringing
back a lot of nostalgia now of course my
Rooks attacked I think a lot of people
who maybe are new to this position would
play Rook B1 but the move to play as far
as I remember is Queen to
B3 I think Bishop A3 is also possible
but Queen B3 has the idea of hitting the
bishop and the pawn on
F7 and I'm leaving my
Rook just available for capture we're
already going to see another example of
why you should
prioritize peace activity and initiative
over material at least in some
cases and there's not too many options
for black in this position like if black
wants to save F7 with a move like
casling or queen E7 then I'll take the
bishop and be up
material uh we see D5 D5 maybe is one of
the best
moves although I think I'm happy to take
the pawn
and keep all of the
attack I can't recall if I studied this
exact position in the past but
uh yeah I mean I still have the
initiative against F7 and the
bishop and I lose a rook gu D5 was
useful in ensuring that black has some
development but I'm going to take the
pawn
King has to choose between a couple
squares
there and
now it's interesting because I've like I
learned this position when I was younger
without the inclusion of of
D5 so I've basically learned the
position with a pawn still on D7 after
which the best move would be Bishop G5
to provoke Knight E7 I can show this
after the game too and then Knight E5
would be very strong um but because
black no longer has a d
Pawn if I play Bishop G5 the queen can
move up I guess then I could
recapture but I'm thinking it might be
more effective here to play Bishop
A3 which essentially exploits the fact
black can't block with D6 the D Pawn is
no longer there and that will be forcing
Knight E7
so yeah let's go for Bishop
A3 and I know in most games uh
throughout the speedrun series I have
not relied on like deep opening
preparation but I guess this one is a
bit of an exception we did go into one
of the more critical but also like super
interesting lines and
um yeah it looks good for white uh just
with the the two Bishops and the queen
seems like like there should be like
some mating
ideas despite the fact I'm
down how much am I down a rook
and oh pawns are equal so I'm down the
whole Rook here um I could take back the
bishop but sometimes when you see like
an obvious move you want to still look
for your other
options and I think the maybe there's a
couple Alternatives I'm I'm considering
in here one is Rook E1 to attack the
pinned Knight the other is Knight E5
which maybe looks a little bit slow
because I'm losing D4 but there's a
calculation Knight E5 let's say Bishop
takes D4 looks most natural and then
Bishop
G6 with idea that I'm threatening Queen
F7
Checkmate and the bishop and the Knight
would be supporting F7 and even though
black could take the bishop or the
Knight then the other piece will still
be helping out with a
Checkmate
so yeah this is definitely requiring
like higher level calculation than
normally you would see at this rating
level but I think I'm going to go for
Knight
E5 and this isn't really like there's
definitely a difference between hope
chess where you're like you're maybe
playing suboptimal moves hoping your
opponent goes wrong but this is more
just trying to
play what the position calls for I think
because I've sacrificed a lot of
material I want to be as aggressive as
possible I don't want to waste time
recapturing the bishop even though that
was probably a fine option uh because if
I get in this move Bishop
G6 like there's so few resources for
black to stop
Queen
F7 and the knight's pinned so the Knight
nor the queen can really help block on
D5 yeah I'm gonna play Bishop
G6 and this is an idea I learned when I
was like pretty young this uh so-called
clearance idea coming from this exact
opening another big shout out to Tamara
um I'll have to email her link to this
video once it's posted
but yeah I I'm pretty sure the the
Tactics still work in this position like
I really don't see a defense for
black like there's so few moves that
black can play that don't get M it
immediately like this doesn't really
work because then The Rook gets involved
Queen E8 would delay the mate but I'm
happy to win the queen there and queen
D5 I just take it the knight's pinned
and to be fair to my opponent like they
really did nothing obviously wrong in
this game like they took free material
they just walked into a super venomous
opening
line which um I think is going to lead
to a quick win for
light opponent is taking time here
but I think it's uh a little bit too
late I will say that like the mistake
from black
was taking the material on
C3 uh and actually in this
position the best move is Bishop takes
C3 as far as I know but taking twice on
C3 is um as we've seen in this game it
runs into a lot of
trouble so opponent does have some
time to ponder maybe regret their
earlier life
decisions and I think what I'll do is
after the game I will give an opening
lesson on uh this opening of like how to
respond as black but uh yeah okay Queen
F7 winning the game in 16
moves um yeah hopefully this will give
some inspiration to even some white
players that want to splice up their
their white opening reper be a bit more
aggressive
less materialistic from early
on but uh yeah if we go back
to I mean even to this position um and
we'll look from black
side and hopefully this will be a useful
lesson to uh my opponent but to anyone
who plays this as black so after D4
taking and Bishop B4 is the best
continuation but after Knight
C3 takes and castle uh black should take
with the bishop here and I actually
wasn't going to take back I was going to
play the move D5 this is the main line
if white takes back then D5 is a really
nice move to attack the bishop support
the Knight get R to Castle and black is
up a pawn here so this is known to be a
little bit preferable for
black but after um after
D5 after Bishop takes C3 and D5 then
black should play the move uh Bishop F6
save the
bishop and yeah it's kind of a long
theoretical line but I'll just show how
it goes Rook E1 counterattacking the
Knight black should save this Knight and
then after takes uh there's this move
Pawn D6 uring white doesn't get to play
D6 and Theory keeps going here uh Bishop
G5 is the main line after takes takes
black should not Castle because that
walks into some crazy Knight sack
followed by the queen and Rook doubling
up so black should play H6 and then the
main line here is Queen E2 takes Rook e
one and white has a triple battery on
the E file black has to lose back the
piece black should play Bishop E6 and
after takes Pawn F6 and this is a line
that uh yeah my my early chess coach
taught me when I was pretty young and I
I used to play this for both sides
objectively black is a bit for Choice
here because Black's up a pawn even
though White's pieces look menacing uh
all the pieces are basically blocked by
The blockaded Pawn on E6 so this is a
pretty well-known position for anyone
that plays this opening for either color
but uh yeah hopefully uh an important
opening lesson to take away for anyone
that didn't know this
previously so uh let's move on we're two
games in do another 10-minute game
playing
Sala from the country of
UAE let's play
E4 um I'll play Knight to
F3 I was in the UAE a few times for
various chess events went there for the
world championship match in
2021 I believe whenever Magnus played
nepo also played in Abu Dhabi about a
year ago so okay we'll play the same
opening Italian Bishop
C4 ooh F5 so this is called the Roo
Gambit
and it's not an opening I've looked so
much
into it's very similar to the Shan
Gambit which is when white has a bishop
on B5 that's a variation within the Roy
Lopez um
um yeah so I guess I should explain that
the point is if I take
on F5 then black can expand with
combination of D5 and or
E4 and yeah that gets a lot of
initiative so I definitely don't want to
take the pawn as far as I know the best
move here is to play Pawn
D4 to counter strike in the center and
now the idea is okay I can recapture on
E5
so we're basically trading pawns and
because black has moved the F Pawn then
the king is a bit more
exposed
although it's hard to exploit like a
move like Queen H5 runs into
G6 I don't think that really achieves
anything meanwhile yeah my Pawn's
attacked I was briefly looking at takes
takes and then Queen H5 hitting H7 but
after G6 that defends H7 so I don't
think I want to trade off my developed
bishop or the undeveloped
Knight I mean the obvious move is Bishop
to
F4 defending the pawn and developing
This would run into Queen
B4 and let's say Knight D2 defending the
bishop I lose a
pawn I'm going to go for this line and
we're sticking with the theme so far of
uh today's games is I'm
prioritizing peace
development and early activity over
material it was not my intention to
basically try and sacrifice every game
early in the opening but just kind of
stumbling into such positions but D5 is
kind of
surprising because the Pawn's not
defended maybe my opponent's trying to
develop the bishop
but I don't think I mind taking the pawn
there's two ways to take the pawn I
could take with bishop or take on
pant I think I just want to take with
Bishop I always have to ask if black has
any like strong tactics and response
but I don't really see any way to
exploit the bishop on
D5 a move like E3 would attack my Bishop
on F4 but then I can just take with
bishop or
Pawn and
now I mean black giving me some gifts E4
is not
defended and even though my Knight's
pinned the Knight still helps defend the
bishop because once the queen takes and
the knight's no longer
pinned so rather than being down the
pawn which I thought I was going to be
after Queen B2 uh I'm now up two
pawns so life is pretty
good
a few moves come to mind here I could
Castle I could play
C3 Rook B1 I don't want to play there's
no reason to defend B2 when Queen takes
B2 walks into Rook B1 be happen happy to
open the
file so I'm considering Queen
H5 Queen H5 does run into Bishop
F7
so probably just castling get the king
out of the
center black is maybe likely to Castle
Queen
side and there is this pin the Knight
was pinned to the king but now it's
pinned to the
queen so let's move the
queen and everything's defended here
Knight's defended twice Bishop's
defended B7 isn't defended but or B2 is
not defended I should should say but
it's a pawn I would be happy to
lose and it's actually a pawn that I'll
I'll try and provoke black to
take I'm going to play
C3 now especially in a case with
opposite side
castling it's so useful to to try and
get initiative or get an attack on the
side where the Pawn's King is my OPP's
trying to pawnor maybe with H6 preparing
G5 so I'd like to start generating
threats u i mean I could Pawn swor with
B4
B5 or even A4 A5 A6 is an
idea Queen E3 comes to mind hit A7 can
be met with King
B8 another move I kind of like is Knight
C4 preparing Knight D6 let's go for
this and if Bishop takes C4 then Black's
trading off one of the only develop
pieces the only develop minor
piece black doesn't take the Knight so
this gives me a chance to go in with
check Knight is very strong here
supported by the pawn this is an outpost
that's very deep in Black's
position now it's a question should I
keep my Bishop
supporting the pawn and also the Knight
or do I move the bishop back Target
A7 I'm going to move it
back I just like
the the image of the two Bishops on E5
like they control so many squares and
especially the attacking potential now
is um is very high black saxs exchange
which is probably a good practical
option the Knight was very very strong
there
but of course the downside for black is
I'm up material the defile is
opened I'm going to keep a initiative I
have the move Bishop to D4
here which almost traps a
rook yeah uh maybe black didn't realize
I was covering
H7 if we just go back Bishop G7 was
possible okay opponent resigns so uh
kind of a rough finish there I'll just
show that Bishop G7 would have perhaps
been a better try because it's supported
by the queen but then I can take and
then take and then check and life is
very good King C7 maybe Queen D2 or Rook
eight and white has a material advantage
and the initiative as
well so yeah going back in this game um
I mean I don't think I did anything so
special think I I did know how to
respond to this opening like this move
d4 I didn't really know any Theory
Beyond this
position and the resulting position uh
yeah black was I guess a little bit slow
to develop I managed to develop three
minor pieces before black had any of
these guys developed and then D4 or D5
and then allowing me to capture two free
pawns some nice uh Christmas presents
I'm still recording this on December
25th so okay uh pretty smooth game let's
keep it
going I am trying to live up to the
promise of a longer
episode so let's uh yeah let's play the
same openings another Kings
pong so I played over 50 games so far in
the
speedrun and it feels like the vast
majority have been in a a Kings Pawn
opening a E4 E5 we have seen a few
Spanish openings so far I'll play A6
Main
Line Spanish also known as a Roy Lopez
Bishop A4 is the main move and I'm going
to play uh Pawn D6 this is the steinis
defense and it's another opening that uh
my coach tamari goov taught me from uh
very early
on and cing is very natural I'll play
Knight
F6 I think it was a few episodes ago I
showed the Noah's Arc trap which can
stem from D4 and then B5 and then
there's a line where if white like does
trade everything on D4 black can
potentially win material and we might
see this play
out
so want to be sure that it's working
though if I play B5 here there is Pawn
takes
Pawn although then I can take the bishop
and then take back I think that's okay
for
black so let's go for
B5 I mean the main trap what we call the
no isarc trap is if Bishop
B3 then takes takes takes takes and then
will'll be blocked to move and win
material I me first we'll see if uh if
it plays out if it doesn't play out I'll
show show everything after the
game White's taking time here which is
already a sign that uh yeah opponent
like has identified the critical moment
because Bishop B3 is not the only move I
can consider D5 or taking both moves
counterattacking one of the
knights
I'm pretty sure Bishop B3 is like a
tactical
mistake oh opponent
disconnected maybe some internet
issues I don't think there's any reason
to rage quit so early when uh yeah
things are just heating
up is the auto resign
incoming oh
no it kind of makes me sad like I wanted
to to play out the game
but okay game abandoned gain 15 points
there so yeah let me show let me let me
at least give an opening
lesson uh going back so when black plays
D6 in this opening the main
trap is when mik plays D4
immediately and uh this is like the
classic know his Arc trap black plays B5
Bishop B3 takes takes takes takes I'm
pretty sure I showed this exact line in
um previous speedrun episode but the key
move is C5 here attacking the queen
threatening
C4 uh black does have to be careful
because after Queen D5 these things are
attacked but then there's a move Bishop
E6 defending the pawn and The Rook after
this this this the rook's now defend did
Black can play C4 and wi material
obstructing the Queen Bishop battery so
going back to what happened in the game
because white castled first in this
position it was a little bit
different
and I'm just going to check to see yeah
the best move for white would have been
to take on
E5 and I was actually calculating Pawn's
Bishop which is not the best move we see
the engine now really favoring white
after takes
takes I guess it makes sense that the
this Pawn is super weak Knight D5 also
incoming so if white took the pawn on
E5 black should just take back
apparently allow the queen
trade take with the Knight the bishop
still attacked after Bishop
B3 then then black has some choices
Bishop D6 is maybe the most solid
defending the pawn E4 is pressured
Bishop B7 coming casting is coming it
would have been a pretty balanced game
from here so anyway it's kind of sad
that uh we didn't get to see the game
play out but I'll take the rating and we
will move on another game
playing Narin Dr abadam I'll
play E4 apologies if I butchered that
name but uh okay opponent from the USA
and what are we going to see here paent
taking some
time Pawn
E5 so every game this episode King's
Pawn
opening we see the
filor now there's a bunch of moves that
are very playable for white uh I think
I'll just play Bishop C4 get ready to
Castle as quickly as
possible and yeah Bishop G4
so what episode was it it was
episode
15 it was just the last episode that I
had the uh the really nice legal's
Checkmate trap where if Knight C6 okay
we're not going to see it here if you
want to see how that would play out uh
watch the previous episode was a a nice
opening trap that would involve a queen
sacrifice but from here yeah I'm not
meeting uh black defended against the
simple M
threat I think here it's just a matter
of developing I'll play D3 get ready to
get the bishop and
play Black could maybe go for Knight C6
Knight
D4 and then I might have to go back to
D1 generally when the player develops
her Bishop early and then trades for the
Knight on a square like
F3 then like it's already a slight
inaccuracy for black because I'm able to
activate the queen in previous games we
saw why it's not a good idea to bring
out the queen early but there's always
exceptions to this Rule and this is a
case where the queen I think is is happy
to be out and and maybe used as a
attacking weapon like I could consider
Queen G3
here I think I'll go ahead and
play this move aligns with the King
prepares Bishop H6 it also prepares a
move like Pawn F4 if I want to open the
f file get the Rook
involved we see Pawn A5 which not sure
if this really has any
purpose although maybe black wants to
play C6 and then B5 and eventually trap
the bishop so I do have to be somewhat
of alert of uh the danger on the queen
side but here I'll go ahead and play
Bishop
H6 very simple
threat if Knight H5 I can move the queen
to G4 keeping the pin and attack in the
Knight Knight E8 is probably the safer
move like even though it's really
passive it does prevent me from
checkmating and
now I'd like to keep the attack going a
couple moves come to mind I mean Pawn F4
and Knight
D5 I think are the logical ways forward
if I play Pawn
F4 I do have to be careful of allowing
my Bishop to get trapped like then King
h8 and if I play Bishop
G5 Pawn F6 Bishop
H4 it's still probably
okay
but it's actually not easy to like crack
the setup
here I'm also looking at potential ways
to like sacrifice a
bishop but yeah I'm going to go for Pawn
F4 don't want to be wasting any time and
I don't think the bishop is getting
trapped like King h8 I can play Bishop
G5 and in the event of trading then the
file opens which would be quite nice so
black develops Knight reinforcing
E5 and I'm actually not sure like if I
want to play F5 and gain space or if I
want to take and open the file or if I
want to leave the
tension I'll take a moment here
to consider the
options I think I I want to leave the
tension like with either move it feels a
bit too
committal I think I'd rather just get
the Knight into play just applying more
pressure creating ideas of Knight takes
Bishop yeah sometimes positions like
this you just want to keep building up
the
pressure until there's just enough
straws to break the camels
back uh my opponent being the camel in
this case so we see
C6 I'm going to take the bishop this is
one of the points is to remove Black's
final bishop and now I have the bishop
pair and assuming the queen
takes I do have Bishop G5
now the bishop Bishop served its purpose
on
H6 now it's attacking the queen F6 is
not playable because the pawn is
pinned I guess I I should be aware that
black is threatening to play B5 and b b
3 A4 to trap the bishop so if I want to
be safe I could play
A4 ensuring that Bishop won't get
trapped I'm considering
this but I'm not
seeing not seeing any way to like win
anything
concretely Pawn or queen
takes so I think I will play
A4 not only preventing B5 but giving the
bishop some room to move
back and I think this position calls for
a very common type of thought process in
the middle game is to identify which
piece is doing nothing in the position
and make it do something and that piece
is a rook on A1 would really like to
enter the game and because the file is
very very likely to open I think the
plan should be to double up the
Rooks it's also question like what is
black
doing actually
black has left the Knight less defended
here I'm not going to uh I'm not going
to focus on doubling up the Rooks
immediately I like the idea of just
opening that file cuz if Pawn
takes then I take and I'm just crushing
cuz G G Pawn is pinned and there's no
Knight to
recapture if the queen
takes we won't we won't see
that maybe after the game I can analyze
if uh if the queen were to
take yeah here we see the power of the
the open file along with the queen align
with the King maybe at some point black
should have moved the king off the G
file
but not only did I win the Knight I'm
now attacking the queen and threatening
mate black does
check my king so let's move
over I think we're going to see
G6 now the plan is very simple Queen H6
and queen
G7 it is possible for black to defend
with one of these
moves
but life is very good here up
a
bishop and I have the Ming
attack I'm looking for Force mate
but I mean if Queen here Knight here I
take and then I'm just mating Queen here
Knight
E8 I'm not seeing
it I mean it's still of course very good
for whites
but I
mean is there anything
[Music]
better I could save the bishop I could
play a there's a lot of good-looking
moves Play Bishop
E7 I could take on E5 repairing Queen
F6 I'm just going to save the bishop I
wasn't sure what to do there um I think
like there are just a lot of winning
moves
but I think that was a case where
hopefully patience will pay
off do have to move a little bit quicker
here you of of course A Move Like Bishop
E7 and winning more material then
probably going after F7 is is
suitable but I didn't go for Queen here
because Knight E8 would then attack the
bishop and I didn't want to be in a spot
where both Bishops are
hanging so I'm just kind of resolving
the threats on the queen
side waiting for the right
opportunity there is actually a nice
idea I'm beginning to regret not having
played it
but the idea would be Rook F3 of course
I have to watch out for my back rank
because yeah um I don't want to have an
accident but if I play Rook F3
okay well now I can play Queen
H6 once the game ends all I'll share
what
um probably what I should have gone for
sooner Queen G7 is
now Unstoppable black does have one
spite check yeah this is a case where
black is probably wishing they could
move their Knight back uh back to
E8 to defend the square
okay black
resigns so let me just quickly
show what I
realized I guess in this
position what I could have gone
for I'm pretty sure this works is Rook
F3 and I mean this move would involve
sacrificing the bishop but then very
soon sacrificing the queen and the idea
would be Rook F3 I lose the bishop and
then Queen
H6 and whichever move white plays to
cover G7 let's say Knight E8 then I sack
the queen and this is a really nice
mating pattern Rook H3 King G8 Rook h8
Checkmate so yeah goes to show there
were uh probably a lot of lot of
different ideas to get the job done
there but um yeah overall I think this
is a nice game I uh uh I just followed
opening principles I think we saw kind
of a typical mistake of opponent
bringing out their bishop and then just
trading it
Without Really um really focusing on
developing other
pieces so I it's not like a losing
mistake but it led to a position where I
got the the quicker development the
quicker attack and it led to very good
things so um I think we're going to end
on that one I hope uh hope people could
take away a lot of lessons from these
games if you have questions leave them
below and I look forward to reading the
comments and if you like the content
subscribe stay tuned for more and I'll
see you guys soon